[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin ihnen allen schönen guten
Abend Kristin völlig missratener Start
der Nationalelf ins WM Turnier und du
hast später mehr Spanien der nächste
Gegner hat ja auch gespielt ziemlich gut
guten Abend wir blicken dann auf die
Themenlage
erst Protest dann Pleite mit dieser
Geste setzt die deutsche Mannschaft vor
dem Spiel ein Zeichen gegen die FIFA und
verliert dann mit 1 zu 2 gegen Japan
Schlagabtausch im Bundestag Deutschland
sei Krisen und winterfest sagt der
Kanzler der
Oppositionsführer kritisiert die
Energiepolitik der Regierung
und ein Raub wie im Gangsterfilm
unbekannte stehlen Goldmünzen im
Millionenwert aus einem Museum im
bayerischen manche
[Musik]
ja riesen Enttäuschung nach der eins zu
zwei Niederlage gegen Japan wieder ein
völlig verkorkter Start in die
Fußball-WM wieder sorgten im Vorfeld
nicht sportliche Themen für Unruhe die
Nationalmannschaft verzichtete ja auf
Druck der FIFA auf die One Love
Kapitänsbinde die für Diversität werden
sollte daraufhin viel Kritik weswegen
das Team vor dem Spiel heute ein Zeichen
setzte über die Niederlage und das
Drumherum Boris Büchler im frustmodus es
herrscht Ernüchterung und Enttäuschung
der Auftakt ging völlig daneben von
daher kann ich schon verstehen dass die
Spieler das Spiel ein bisschen ratlos
sind aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es so
dass wir zwei Spielen noch vor der
Brüste haben und wir wollen unbedingt da
ja letztendlich die Gruppenphase
überstehen viele hätten sich gewünscht
dass hier die One Love Binde hängt aber
Manuel Neuer trägt wie erwartet dass
offizielle stuckstoff der FIFA kurz war
Anpfiff dann doch noch einen stiller
Protest beim Teamfoto eine Geste die
bedeuten soll könnt uns nicht den Mund
verbieten eine deutliche Kritik am
Weltverband und dessen Verbotspolitik es
ist so dass man uns vielleicht die one
love-binde nehmen kann aber man kann
unsere Stimme nicht nehmen und deshalb
uns zum Schweigen zu bringen damit ist
glaube ich keine gute Idee und deshalb
haben wir dieses Zeichen gesetzt in
einer durchwachsenen ersten Halbzeit
wird David Raum von Torwart Gonda
gefoult und es gibt Elfmeter den
Gündogan in der 33 Minute zum eins zu
null verwandelt in der zweiten Hälfte
viele Chancen für das fliegt-team doch
Japan macht das Tor Duran der Stürmer
vom SC Freiburg mit dem 1:1 in der 75 in
der Abwehr völliges Chaos Schlotterbeck
schwach und Asano vom VfL Bochum mit dem
21 Sieg Treffer in der 83 ein
riesendämpfer für das fliegt ihn
Flagge zeigt die bundesinnenministerin
die während des Spiels die one love-
[Applaus]
ja also ich finde es gut dass sie klare
Kante zeigt das ist auch richtig so
sportlich am Tag der verpassten Chancen
sportpolitisch aber haben sie zumindest
eine kleine Chance genutzt
wir gehen zu Sven Forst vor dem
khalifa-stadion wo die Nationalelf hier
spielt ist wenn bittere und
enttäuschende Niederlage woran lagst
ja die deutsche Mannschaft hat sich
diese Auftakt Niederlage gegen Japan
natürlich selbst zuzuschreiben und die
Spieler suchen auch gar nicht nach
Ausflüchten wenn man über 70 Minuten den
Gegner so dominiert wenn man sich so
viele Torchancen herausspielt und wenn
man dann eben auch drei in der 33
Minuten in Führung geht dann darf man
dieses Spiel einfach nicht mehr
verlieren aber es gab diese Momente z.B
den als die deutsche Mannschaft angreift
und viermal aufs Tor schießt der Japaner
und viermal Wert der japanische Torhüter
ab sowas ist natürlich auch
demoralisieren dann kam Fehler auf in
der deutschen Defensive die war etwas
luftig unterwegs und dann auch Fehler im
Spiel aufbauen letzten Endes verliert
man gegen Japan 1:2 nicht unbedingt
viele stören Momente im Vorfeld
Stichwort One Love bin wie sehr hat denn
diese Debatte geschafft
also natürlich ging das alles an den
deutschen Spielern nicht vorbei weil ich
hatte eher den Eindruck dass es so eine
Art trotz Reaktion gab das hat man ja
auch vor Spielbeginn gesehen als die
Spieler sich gegen die FIFA Zensur zur
Wehr gesetzt haben indem sie die Hand
vor den Mund gehalten haben auf der
Tribüne wurden die Mannschaft
unterstützt von der Innenministerin
Nancy fazer die ein breites Kreuz machte
und mit der one love-binden neben FIFA
Boss Gianni in fantino stand also ich
würde sagen am Ende hat man zwar gegen
Japan auf dem Platz verloren aber nicht
gegen die FIFA danke für die
Einschätzung nach Kata Sven vosswalders
mehr WM über die deutschen Fans in Katar
und den Sieg der Spanier gegen Costa
Rica dann später hier bei uns in der
Sendung jetzt zum politischen Duell hier
bei uns
Oppositionsführer gegen Bundeskanzler
das stand heute im Fokus der
generalaussprache im Bundestag
traditionell ist das ein eher deftigerer
Schlagabtausch und die Zeit der
Abrechnung mit der Bundesregierung ob
Unionsfraktion auf märz die Chance
nutzte wie die Replik ausfiel und welche
Rolle Kinderbücher dabei spielen dazu
Winnie Hischer
so ein Bild
passierte März kräftig aneinandergeraten
heute ist der Ton schon in diesem Bild
gesetzt Friedrich Merz wird mit der
Scholz Regierung abrechnen allerdings
milder als zuletzt er kritisiert vor
allem die Energiepolitik Strom
gaspreisbremse akaviel Laufzeiten sie
können es vielleicht nicht besser das
ändert sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
das Tragische daran ist nur dass die
Lage für Millionen von Haushalten und
Menschen in diesem Land von Tag zu Tag
schwieriger wird dass viele Menschen
heute am Ende des Monats nicht wissen
wie sie das Ende des Monats erreichen
sollen auf der Regierungsbank nimmt man
die Kritik gelassen Scholz zählt auf was
seine Regierung im letzten Jahr alles
geleistet habe fast 100 Gesetze er
kontert für seine Verhältnisse
ungewöhnlich literarisch als ich ihn
gerade zugehört habe musste ich an Alice
im Wunderland denken
was sind Wahrheit groß ist das Reden sie
klein und umgekehrt was eigentlich
passiert ist und wer dafür
verantwortlich war das alles verschwimmt
und was zunächst logisch klingt ist in
Wahrheit blanker Unsinn wir fehlt
ehrlich bei dieser Bundesregierung nur
eins ein Jim Knopf und der Scheinriese
je näher man ihrer Bundesregierung kommt
umso kleiner werden ihre politischen
Leistungen das ist die Realität
Märchenstunde im Plenum die anderen
Oppositionsparteien konzentrieren sich
auf die wirtschaftliche Lage im Land
zwölf Monate Ampel das sind 12 Monate
mutwillige Zerstörung unserer Wirtschaft
und unseres Wohlstandes viele Menschen
fühlen sich eben nicht beschützt und
unterstützt von ihrer Regierung die
fühlen sich schlicht ausgeliefert sie
haben das Gefühl dass sie die Folgen von
Krieg und Krise allein tragen müssen
dass sie die Zeitenwende bezahlen müssen
und ein bisschen wird auch gelacht weil
Friedrich Merz Herr Merkel genannt wird
aus Versehen von der FDP es ging schon
mal dazu im Parlament als bei dieser
Generaldebatte
die Rettung des Energiekonzerns Juniper
wird deutlich teurer als geplant das
bisherige 8 Milliarden Hilfspaket vom
Staat reiche nicht aus so Deutschlands
größter gasimporteur Juniper soll jetzt
weitere 25 Milliarden Euro bekommen
durch die Ausgabe von Aktien die nur vom
Bund erworben werden dürfen ja gerade
haben wir noch über die Generaldebatte
im Bundestag berichtet da ging es auch
um die 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen zur Modernisierung der
Bundeswehr was als Zeitenwende
angekündigt war kommt nach Ansicht der
Opposition nicht richtig voran von dem
Etat wurden bislang 8,4 Milliarden fest
eingeplant viel zu wenig um die
anstehenden Großprojekte des
Verteidigungsministeriums zu realisieren
so lautet die Kritik den us-tarnkappen
jetf 35 z.B den Transporthubschrauber ch
47 und den Schützenpanzer Puma mehr weiß
jetzt Thomas Reichert
neun Monate nach dem Olaf Scholz seine
zeitenwände für die Bundeswehr versprach
ist dort noch wenig angekommen
Scholz verteidigt das heute im Bundestag
neue Waffen und Munition bräuchten einen
längeren Vorlauf das geht dann plötzlich
nicht mehr zu sagen wir brauchen noch
mal Nachschub für die Munition weil
diese Anlagen gar nicht mehr in Betrieb
sind wir müssen mit dem was wir
entscheiden auch dafür sorgen dass wir
jeder Belastungssituation gerecht werden
können und auch das ist das was wir mit
dem Sondervermögen jetzt machen aus dem
Sondervermögen fließen im nächsten Jahr
8,4 Milliarden Euro der
Verteidigungshaushalt selbst aber
schimpft erst mal auf gut 50 Milliarden
entgegen ihrer Zusage steigt der
Verteidigungshaushalt nämlich nicht etwa
auf die verabredeten zwei Prozent er
singt im nächsten Jahr um fast 300
Millionen Euro Herr Bundeskanzler ich
kann es nicht anders sagen das ist ein
grober Wortbruch es fehlt dann viele
Männer nein 20 Milliarden bei der
Munition die aber auch nicht rechtzeitig
bestellt wurde die Bundeswehr ist nach
wie vor im freien Fall das heißt wir
haben enorme Probleme Stichwort
Mangelwirtschaft die wir haben und
gleichzeitig Abgabe von Waffensystemen
beispielsweise an die Ukraine ich glaube
das die Zeiten wenn der mental noch
nicht bei allen auch im
Verteidigungsministerium und weiter
darüber hinaus angekommen ist so dass
man wirklich verstanden hat dass man
hier im Grunde genommen quasi Tag und
Nacht daran arbeiten muss dass sie
umgesetzt wird zumindest für die
nächsten Jahre hat die Regierung
angekündigt den Verteidigungsetat zu
erhöhen und dann noch die Lücken bei
Waffen und Munition zu schließen
8,5% mehr Geld das hatten die IG Metall
und Arbeitgeber in Baden-Württemberg
gerade erst vergangene Woche beschlossen
jetzt zieht der erste Großkonzern nach
und zwar Volkswagen vW übernimmt den
Pilotabschluss für seine
125.000 Beschäftigten in Westdeutschland
für sie kommt die Lohnsteigerung in zwei
Schritten ab Juni 2023 bekommen sie 5,2%
mehr Gehalt und ab Mai 2024 noch mal 3,3
% mehr außerdem als Inflationsausgleich
3000 €, die auch in zwei Schritten
ausgezahlt werden
vor genau 30 Jahren warfen Neonazis in
Schleswig-Holstein Molotow-Cocktails in
zwei Häuser in denen türkische Familien
wohnten drei Menschen starben darunter
ein 14 und ein zehnjähriges Mädchen
heute wurde an verschiedenen Orten der
Opfer gedacht an den anschlagsorten in
der Stadt Mölln wurden Grenzen
niedergelegt bei einem interreligiösen
Gottesdienst rief kulturstaatsministerin
Claudia Roth zu einem verstärkten Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus auf
jetzt in die Ukraine wo nach massiven
russischen Angriffen in weiten Teilen
des Landes der Strom ausgefallen ist
dadurch wurden auch mehrere mehrere
ukrainische Atomkraftwerke durch ein
Notfallsystem automatisch vom Netz
getrennt unter anderem in der Hauptstadt
Kiew viel zudem die Wasserversorgung aus
nach einem Besuch im zurück eroberten
Herr Sonne im Süden des Landes ist unser
Reporter Henna Hebestreit jetzt 50 km
westlich in der Stadt mikolaje und Henna
Frage an dich gibt es weiter massiven
russischen Beschuss in der Region wie
erlebst du die Situation
also im Moment ist es hier ruhig aber
als wir ein Restaurant waren und das
gewinnere alle Augenblicke gehört haben
von der russischen Artillerie die über
den Fluss in die Stadt reingeschossen
haben piepten die Handys und alle paar
Minuten gab es gab es Nachrichten über
schweren Raketenbeschuss im ganzen Land
die der kritischen Infrastruktur der
Ukraine auf meinen weiten Teil den Rest
gegeben haben du hast es gesagt mehrere
Atomkraftwerke geworden heruntergefahren
teilweise in die Notabschaltung und hier
in nikolaiv ist der Supermarkt hinter
mir das einzige und wirklich das einzige
Gebäude das beleuchtet ist dass ich
daran dass sie dort einen
Notstromaggregat haben man kann also
einkaufen gehen aber schon was bezahlen
wird schwierig es gibt kein Internet
also kann man mit der Karte wieder
bezahlen noch Geld abheben und das Handy
das wird sich auch bald verabschieden
die Batterien die die Antennen in den
notstromodus versetzen halten maximal
vier bis fünf Stunden den Menschen in
der Ukraine steht also eine dunkle und
kalte Nacht bevor ja bittere Aussichten
danke nach nicolayef Hannah Hebestreit
war das gleich zwei Anschläge haben im
morgendlichen Berufsverkehr den Großraum
jerusale erschüttert ein Teenager starb
mindestens 18 Menschen wurden verletzt
einige schwer an zwei Bushaltestellen im
Norden der Stadt explodierte je eine
Bombe die israelische Polizei sprach von
einer koordinierten Attacke die
palästinensische Maß bekannte sich zwar
nicht sprach aber von einer heldenhaften
Operation seit einiger Zeit schaukeln
sich die Spannungen zwischen Israel und
den Palästinensern wieder hoch
in die USA zwei Tage vor dem so
wichtigen Feiertag zum Erntedankfest als
viele Menschen ihre Einkäufe erledigten
hat im Bundesstaat Virginia ein
Angreifer in einem Supermarkt sechs
Menschen erschossen und mehrere verletzt
der mutmaßliche Schütze tötete sich
selbst und war Mitarbeiter des
Supermarktes so die Behörden erst am
Wochenende waren in einem Nachtclub im
Bundesstaat Colorado fünf Menschen
erschossen worden
wer wird als nächster Europäer oder
nächste Europäerin ins All fliegen die
europäische Raumfahrtagentur hat das
jetzt entschieden aus mehr als
22.500 Bewerbern wurden fünf Astronauten
ausgewählt neben ihnen wurden auch
Raumfahrer in Reserve bekannt gegeben
darunter Nicola Winter und Amelie
schönen Wald aus Deutschland erstmals
wird mit dem dritten John mcfall auch
ein Astronaut mit Behinderung
ausgebildet
und jetzt zu einem Fall wie im Krimi aus
dem Kelten Römermuseum im bayerischen
Manching wurden gestern früh fast 500
keltische Goldmünzen gestohlen die sind
mehr als 2000 Jahre alt und rund 1,6
Millionen Euro wert während der Tat gab
es offenbar keinen Alarm der Grund
unbekannte hatten in der Nacht mehrere
Glasfaserkabel durchschnitten wo durch
Telefon und Internetverbindungen
unterbrochen waren über den gestohlenen
Goldschatz berichtet Christoph Wiesel
Spuren der Zerstörung nach einem Raub
der weit über das bayerische manchen
hinaus für Aufsehen sorgt der größte
keltische Goldfund des 20 Jahrhunderts
über Nacht von dem erbeutet wurde durch
einen Notausgang verschafften sich die
Täter Zugang brachen die Vitrine mit dem
Schatz auf
sie ging dann noch eine weitere
Beziehung an sehr Sie weitere drei
Goldmünzen entwendeten und verließen
dann wieder das Museum das ganze hat nur
neun Minuten gedauert entdeckt wurde der
Einbruch erst Stunden später denn kurz
vor dem Diebstahl hatten Unbekannte
Telefon und Internet in der Gegend
lahmgelegt der Alarm im Museum wurde
dadurch nicht weitergeleitet die
Vermutung ein gezielter professionell
geplanter Sabotageakt
das ist im Moment auch Gegenstand
unserer Ermittlungen
welche Verbindungslinien es hier
zwischen den beiden Sachverhalten gibt
geprüft werden auch Zusammenhänge mit
früheren Raubüberfällen die akute
Befürchtung die Täter könnten die Münzen
einschmelzen und für den Goldwert
veräußern sie sind so gut dokumentiert
dass sie jederzeit festgestellt werden
können dass sie aus diesen Münzschatz
eben stammen also insofern sind sie auch
nicht einfach im normalen Markt ohne
dass sie entdeckt werden verhandelbar
die Suche nach Dieben und Schatz läuft
noch hat meine Museum Hoffnung das Stück
Geschichte das gestohlen wurde zurück zu
bekommen
tja von einem brutal enttäuschenden WM
Auftakt sprach der Bundestrainer und den
Fans wird wahrscheinlich genauso gehen
Christian peinlich bis selbst schuld die
ganze Palette keine Kosten gescheut und
mit großen Erwartungen nach Katar
gereist und nun gleich zu Beginn völlig
frustriert eine Niederlage im ersten
Spiel wie zuletzt auch 2018 als das
Bittere WM Vorrunden aus folgte das muss
auch von den Fans erstmal verkraftet
werden
Michael Kruska und Stefan Zeit vom
Fanclub Nationalmannschaft beide sind
heute morgen aus Dubai eingeflogen um
ihr Team zu unterstützen
entfernt doch geben sie alles doch dann
das zweite Tor für Japan die
Enttäuschung Fassungslosigkeit so haben
sich die Fans den Staat in die WM nicht
vorgestellt
wie soll ich mich nach dem Spiel
wohlfühlen also das ist eine der größten
Enttäuschungen ich habe nicht damit
gerechnet dass die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft unter Hansi Flick
immer noch nicht in der Lage sein wird
ein besseren und auch den überaus
durchschnittlichen Gegner kontrollieren
und Fußball zu spielen als es jetzt hier
getan haben wir haben einen
enttäuschendes Spiel gesehen in unserer
Mannschaft und natürlich hat wm-gefühl
das war ein ganz schwierigen Stadion zu
finden es war überhaupt keine Stimme und
an den Leuten
enttäuscht ziehen sie davon auch vorm
Stadion schlechte Stimmung es war wieder
mal die Abwehr die einfach ein bisschen
geschlafen hat und es macht natürlich
traurig wir müssen jetzt gegen Spanien
gegen Costa Rica gewinnen
riesenjubel dagegen bei den japanischen
Fans mit einem Sieg ihres Teams hatte
wohl kaum jemand gerechnet
standesgemäß und vielversprechen der
Endrunden Start für Deutschlands
nächsten Gegner am Sonntagabend Spanien
der Weltmeister von 2010 dominierte
seine Auftaktpartie gegen Costa Rica und
gewann souverän mit 7:0
Spaniens Trainer Enrique schon früh
beglückt die dritte Großchance sitzt das
1:0 nach Doppelpass mit Gabi durch
Leipzig Dani Almo erst 11 Minuten
gespielt nur 10 Minuten später das 2:0
diesmal trifft Asensio weiter geht's im
zehn Minuten Tag faul Elfmeter verraten
13:0 Spanien einfach hinreißen diese
erste Hälfte spanisches
Durchsetzungsvermögen auch nach der
Pause ferrentoris zum 4:0 und dann
trifft auch noch der erst 18 Jahre alte
Gabi gegen Costa Rica doch das ist
langsam nicht der Schlusspunkt denn in
der 90 Minute überwindet auch so leer
Costa Ricas Torwart der in der
Nachspielzeit auch das
bis zu 7 durch morata hinnehmen muss
da kommt ganz schön was zu auf
Deutschland am Sonntag
allerdings das Verbot der One Love
bindet das Thema 1930 bei ZDF heute live
in der ZDF heute App können gerne alle
mitdiskutieren dann vielen Dank Kristin
vielleicht habe ich ja jetzt ein paar
gute Nachrichten für Sie hier sind die
Lottozahlen die lauten 1 22 25 29 31 49
und die Superzahl 0 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zdf.de bzw auf der ZDF
Textseite 557
zum Wetter so viel neuer Regen ist
unterwegs mehr gleich mit ersten terli
das heute journal mit marinierter Slomka
heute schon um 21 Uhr so viel von uns
morgen gerne wieder um 7 bis dahin eine
entspannten Abend und alles gut
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter neuer Regen ist ja
bereits aufgekommen im Westen
Deutschlands und der setzt sich
allmählich weiter ostwärts durch ja und
dahinter kommt relativ milde Luft und in
der Nacht wandert der Regen weiter bis
etwa zur Elbe über den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen fällt auch Schnee
oberhalb von 600 m ansonsten vor allem
in der Südhälfte viele Wolken kriegen
und als stürmische Böden bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von -3 bis 0 Grad im Osten
und acht Grad am Oberrhein
morgen am Vormittag dann vor allem im
Süden viele Wolken und Regen und auch
Richtung Osten ist es nass aber von
Westen her lockert es auf und dann zum
Nachmittag scheint vor allem dort
verbreitet die Sonne der Regen
verabschiedet sich allmählich und es
lockert weiter auf bei höchsten
Temperaturen von drei bis acht Grad im
Osten und 12 Grad am Niederrhein die
kommenden Tage am Freitag gibt's neuen
Regen vor allem im Westen bei 5 bis 12
Grad am Samstag dann im Osten wegen der
allmählich nachlässt und Sonntag ist es
dann trocken damit ein schöner Abend